Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello. In today's podcast, we're talking about a man who saw himself as an artist, but has gone down as one of the great monsters in history. A politician, a populist, and a performer. But enough of Tom Holland. Let's talk about... Oh, Dominic, so predictable. Yeah, but so satisfying.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好。在今天的播客中，我们要聊的是一个把自己视为艺术家，却在历史上被称为盖世恶魔之一的人。一个政客、一个民粹主义者、一个表演者。好了，汤姆·霍兰德就说到这儿。让我们来谈谈…… 噢，多米尼克，你真是太老套了。对，但让人感觉太爽了。
Yeah, so satisfying yeah so satisfying i suppose i mean what you have a nero is you yeah i mean the man who played nero for me most compellingly was christopher biggins and i think he would do a brilliant tom holland well i'm a bit thinner than christopher biggins you are you are you'd have to lose a bit of weight anyway um so tom nero i mean this is a gift to you. This is one of the great characters. Yeah, I'm really grateful to you for allowing us to do this. In all history. I mean, he really is one of the absolute emblematic characters.
对，太爽了，对，太爽了，我想，我是说，你对尼禄的看法，我是说，对我来说，把尼禄演得最引人入胜的演员是克里斯托弗·比金斯，我觉得他能演个绝佳的汤姆·霍兰德。好吧，我可比克里斯托弗·比金斯瘦一点。你确实是，你确实是，不过你还是得减点肥。总之，嗯，那么，汤姆·尼禄，我的意思是，这简直是老天爷赏饭。这是历史上最了不起的人物之一。对，我真的很感激你让我们来聊这个。在整个历史上。我是说，他绝对是那些最具代表性的标志性人物之一。
Children have heard of Nero. He is the paradigmatic, sort of depraved, corrupt, evil Roman emperor. He is, you know, power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely. And yet, to me, what's fascinating about him, i don't know how far you go along with this is that he like all characters in history has now been revised and now historians say well maybe nero has been introduced by the sources maybe nero is actually a jolly good fellow who's been maligned by suetonius and tacitus and these other sort of snobby you know elit elitist historians. What do you think? Well, I've actually just come back from looking at a new exhibition
小孩子们都听说过尼禄。他是那种典型的堕落、腐败、邪恶的罗马皇帝的化身。他就是那种“权力导致腐败，绝对权力绝对腐败”的写照。然而，对我而言，关于他最令人着迷的地方——我不知道你赞同多少——在于，就像历史上的所有人物一样，他现在已经被重新评估了。现在历史学家会说，好吧，也许尼禄是被史料抹黑了，也许尼禄实际上是个大好人，只是被苏埃托尼乌斯、塔西佗和其他那些傲慢的、精英主义的历史学家给中伤了。你怎么看？嗯，其实我刚看完一个新展览
that's opening at the British Museum on Nero. And it's very good, all kinds of fantastic stuff, wonderful detail, beautifully laid out, highly recommended. But you're right, the theme of it is essentially that Nero wasn't as bad as people made him out to be. And I guess the argument for Nero not having been as bad as people say is that you've got to look at the people who wrote about him. And there were basically two groups of people who wrote about him. group were senators, elite members of the upper classes, who Nero pretty systematically trampled on an awful lot of what they held sacred. And so in a sense, it was inevitable that they were not
它正在大英博物馆展出，主题就是尼禄。展览办得非常好，各种精彩的展品，细节精美，布局考究，强烈推荐。但你说得对，展览的核心主题基本上就是：尼禄其实并没有人们想象的那么坏。我想，关于尼禄其实没那么坏的这种论点，其逻辑在于你必须审视那些撰写关于他历史的人。当时主要有两拨人写过他。其中一拨是元老们，也就是上流社会的精英成员，而尼禄非常系统地践踏了许多他们奉为神圣的东西。因此从某种意义上说，他们是不可能
going to like him. They're sort of Remainers writing the life of Boris Johnson. Is that basically what the story is? Yeah, it's the New York Times on Trump. Right. Yeah. the story is yeah it's it's the new york times on trump right yeah um we don't have the equivalent of fox news would yeah would perhaps be the the analogy um and the other group of people of course are christians um right nero is the beast but they must be writing much much later i suppose are they well the book of revelation which portrays nero as one of the two beasts um and and essentially the the portrait that the book of revelation gives of rome as the whore of babylon as this great sump of depravity and wealth and horror um that's a portrayal of nero's rome and it's because nero uh puts to death
喜欢他的。这就好比是“留欧派”在写鲍里斯·约翰逊的生平。故事基本就是这个调调吗？对，《纽约时报》写特朗普的文章嘛。对。对，故事就是这样，对，《纽约时报》写特朗普的文章嘛，对，我们大概没有福克斯新闻那种对应的视角吧，也许可以这么类比。而另一拨人，当然就是基督徒了。对，尼禄就是那头野兽。不过他们写作的时间肯定要晚得多吧，我想是吗？嗯，《启示录》里把尼禄描绘成两头野兽之一，基本上，《启示录》对罗马的描绘是“巴比伦大淫妇”，把它描绘成一个充满堕落、财富和恐怖的巨大粪坑，这就是对尼禄时代的罗马的描绘。之所以这样，是因为尼禄在大火之后
large numbers of christians after the fire and accuses them of having started this Great Fire of London. Great Fire of London? What am I saying? Great Fire of Rain. That's surely beyond even Nero's powers. Of course, that was the French, wasn't it? Yeah, of course. All right.
处决了大量的基督徒，并指控他们纵火，引发了伦敦大火。伦敦大火？我在说什么呀？降雨大火。这恐怕连尼禄也无能为力吧。当然，那肯定是法国人干的，对吧？对，当然。好吧。
Well, I think you should give us a sort of two-minute overview of Nero's life and reign for those people who are not as familiar with the early days of the Roman Empire as you are. So he's what, the fourth emperor? Is he? He's the fifth emperor. Fifth emperor. So we've had Augustus, Tiberius, Caligula, and Claudius. Yeah, Nero is the great, great grandson of Augustus, the first emperor who's planted an autocracy amid the rubble of what had been Rome's traditional republican
嗯，我觉得你该给我们大致花个两分钟，梳理一下尼禄的生平和统治，好让那些对罗马帝国早期历史不如你那么熟悉的人了解一下。所以他是第几位皇帝？他是吗？他是第五位皇帝。第五位皇帝。所以我们之前有奥古斯都、提比略、卡利古拉和克劳狄乌斯。对，尼禄是奥古斯都的曾外孙。奥古斯都作为第一位皇帝，在罗马传统共和体制的
system. So Nero's line of descent from Augustus is absolutely crucial to his status. He has the blood of a god because Augustus has been deified in his veins. He has been adopted by Claudius, the previous emperor, as his son. And in Rome, to be adopted essentially means you you become his son claudius has married nero's mother who is also his niece because claudius is not descended from augustus agrippina his niece and wife is and so that's that's the kind of crucial channel nero comes to power at the age of 16. He's very much under the thumb of his mother, Agrippina, and of his tutor, Seneca, high-ranking intellectual,
废墟中建立起了一套专制统治。因此，尼禄从奥古斯都那里继承的血统对他的地位至关重要。他的血管里流淌着神的血液，因为奥古斯都已经被神化了。他被前任皇帝克劳狄乌斯收为养子，而在古罗马，被收养基本上意味着你真正成为了他的儿子。克劳狄乌斯娶了尼禄的母亲，而她同时也是克劳狄乌斯的侄女，因为克劳狄乌斯并非奥古斯都的直系后代，而阿格里皮娜——他的侄女兼妻子——则是。所以，这就是那个至关重要的血统渠道。尼禄在16岁时登基。他很大程度上受制于他的母亲阿格里皮娜，以及他的导师塞涅卡——一位高级知识分子，
but also incredibly wealthy and influential. He's a Stoic, isn't he? He's a Stoic, yes. So for the first years of his period in power, Nero is under their thumb and people kind of look back on this as being a period where he ruled quite well. But increasingly, he gets fed up with Seneca, but also particularly with his mother. And he ends up doing what any pissed off teenager would do with his mother. He ends up having her murdered. As you would and from that point on um essentially uh nero takes i mean literally takes the stage he uses um rome and
但同时也极其富有且极具影响力。他是个斯多葛学派学者，对吧？他是个斯多葛学派学者，是的。所以在他统治初期的几年里，尼禄一直受制于他们，人们也把这段时期回顾为他执政相当不错的时期。但渐渐地，他开始厌烦塞涅卡，尤其是厌烦他的母亲。最后，他做出了任何一个被激怒的青少年对母亲都会做的事：他派人谋杀了自己的母亲。理所当然。从那一刻起，嗯，基本上，嗯，尼禄走上了——简直是字面意义上的走上——舞台。他把罗马和
the roman empire as a kind of stage for his incredibly um potent uh alarming, menacing, artistic temperament. But he also literally takes to the stage. I wish the listeners could see this because you're sort of writhing with enthusiasm. With excitement and enthusiasm. Well, I really think he's astonishing because he clearly does have this kind of incredible artistic sensibility. And because he has all these incredible resources, he's able to make it manifest in a way that probably no one else in the entire history of art has ever managed to do. He reminds me, is it James Franco, that American sort of actor, director who makes terrible films and is always really being indulged by the sort of new york critics and stuff isn't he a bit like that no because i think he's i think he's actually quite good and he's also he's he's not he's not he's not a kind of um art house he's
罗马帝国当作一个巨大的舞台，来展现他那极具感染力、令人惊恐、充满威胁的艺术气质。而且他是真的登台表演。我真希望听众们能看到你现在的样子，因为你正兴奋得扭来扭曲。充满了兴奋与热情。好吧，我真的觉得他太惊人了，因为他显然拥有这种极其惊人的艺术敏感度。而且由于他拥有所有这些难以置信的资源，他能够将这一点具象化，这种程度大概是艺术史上任何其他人从未做到过的。他让我想起——是詹姆斯·弗兰科吗？那个美国演员兼导演，拍过烂片，总是备受《纽约时报》等媒体评论界的纵容，他不有点像那样吗？不，因为我觉得他其实挺不错的，而且他也不是那种——他不是那种艺术片导演，他
right hugely populist and that's precisely why he kind of gets resented by the elite he's tom cruise well dominic you'd like him i mean he him. I mean, he's against the sneery metropolitan Remainer elites. And he's one for the people. Right. He's like you. Is he? Yeah. I never thought of myself as like Nero.
非常具有民粹色彩，而这正是他招致精英阶层怨恨的原因。他简直就是汤姆·克鲁斯。好吧，多米尼克，你会喜欢他的。我的意思是，他。我是说，他是反对那些傲慢的伦敦大都会“留欧派”精英的。他是站在人民一边的。对。他就像你一样。是吗？我从来没想过自己会像尼禄。
I always thought of myself as Trajan. So essentially, so just to continue very quickly through the run of his life. Yeah. He is essentially very popular with the masses, very unpopular with the elites. Things are snarled up for him in AD 64 when about, well, two thirds of Rome gets incinerated in a fire. Nero deals with this quite effectively. Lots of poor relief. He puts people
我一直觉得自己像图拉真。所以，总而言之，为了快速把他的生平梳理完。是的，他在群众中非常受欢迎，但在精英阶层中却极其不受欢迎。公元64年，他的好日子遇到了麻烦，当时大约——嗯，罗马大约有三分之二在火灾中被烧为灰烬。尼禄相当有效率地处理了这场灾难。他进行了大量的紧急救济，把人们
up in shanty towns, in public places, starts a huge rebuilding program, rebuilds much of Rome in a much better way, but aggressively appropriates quite a large chunk of it for his own estate, what comes to be called the Golden House. Also commissions
安置在棚户区和公共场所，启动了庞大的重建计划，以好得多面貌重建了罗马的大部分地区，但同时也极具侵略性地将其中相当大的一块划为自己的私产，也就是后来被称为“金宫”的地方。他还委托建造了
a giant statue of the sun, which will go up and give its name to the Colosseum in due course. He then goes on a tour of Greece. While he's in Greece, news comes through that conspirators are moving against him. He comes back. Conspirators move. Everything falls to pieces he flees Rome takes refuge in an out of town villa
一座巨大的太阳神巨像，这座雕像后来倒塌，并最终将名字赋予了罗马斗兽场。随后他去希腊进行了一场巡游。当他在希腊时，消息传来说有阴谋集团正在密谋对付他。他赶了回去。阴谋集团采取了行动。一切分崩离析，他逃离了罗马，在一个城外别墅避难，
the Senate proclaim him a public enemy he commits suicide when he hears the horse beats of coming to arrest him commits suicide his reputation is blackened by subsequent generations but But there are very
元老院宣布他为国家公敌。当他听到前来逮捕他的马蹄声时，他选择了自杀。他自杀了。他的名誉被后世严重抹黑，但
clearly traditions as well, which commemorate him in a much more positive light. And because basically, it's the it's the senatorial elite, and then the Christians who write the history. It's the it's the black reputation that wins out. Wow. Okay. So that's a great overview. Let me rewind right to the beginning, the thing that slightly puzzles me about this story. So Nero is 16. He's never wielded political authority. He hasn't been in the army. He's not a soldier. The Republic is not that long ago. And Rome has had, obviously, Augustus, who was the sort of autocrat who created the Roman Empire.
显然也有一些传统将他纪念为更加正面的人物。而且因为基本上，是元老院精英，然后是基督徒在书写历史，所以最终获胜的是那种恶劣的名声。哇。好的。这是一个很棒的概述。让我把磁带倒回最开始，这个故事里有一点让我感到困惑的地方。尼禄当时16岁。他从未掌握过政治权力，没有参过军，也不是个军人。共和国距离当时并不算太遥远。显然，罗马经历过奥古斯都——那个创建了罗马帝国的专制君主；
It had Tiberius, who'd been a commander. And then it had Curigula, who was a disaster. Claudius, you know, not much of an anything. Why is it that the idea of the sort of next person in line in the family taking power, how has that become so ingrained so quickly that the Senate and all the military commanders and all these other people just automatically think, oh yeah, well, Nero will make a great emperor, let's have him. I mean, why doesn't somebody more experienced or more powerful
经历过曾担任指挥官的提比略；然后是堪称灾难的卡利古拉；还有克劳狄乌斯，你知道的，算不上什么雄主。为什么“家族中顺位下一位继承人接管权力”这种观念会变得如此根深蒂固，以至于元老院、所有的军事指挥官以及其他所有人都会自动觉得：“哦，好吧，尼禄会成为一个伟大的皇帝，就让他来吧”？我是说，当克劳狄乌斯去世时，为什么没有一个更有经验或更有权势的人来取代尼禄呢？因为尼禄的血管里流淌着奥古斯都的血液。人们普遍认为，奥古斯都的继承人应当统治帝国。使情况变得复杂的一个因素是，克劳狄乌斯实际上是个篡位者。所以当卡利古拉被谋杀时——卡利古拉是奥古斯都的后代，从这个意义上说，他被视为合法的——
take over instead of Nero when Claudius dies? Because Nero has the blood of Augustus in his veins. And there is a sense that an heir of Augustus should rule. And one of the things that complicates this is that Claudius is actually a usurper. So when Caligula gets murdered, and Caligula is descended from Augustus, so in that sense, he's seen as legitimate. There is actually a move on the part of the Senate to get rid of the principate, the rule by the princeps, the first man, or perhaps to appoint someone as emperor who is not descended from Augustus. But Claudius, who has been brought up in the Augustan house,
元老院其实曾试图废除元首制（由元首、即第一公民统治的体制），或者考虑任命一位并非奥古斯都后代的人为皇帝。但是克劳狄乌斯在奥古斯都家族中长大，
he is the grandson of Livia, who has married to Augustus and who viewers of I, Claudius will remember is kind of cast as the murderous matriarch. So Claudius kind of rushes off and grabs the Praetorian guard, who are kind of the military presence in Rome. Praetorian Guard, who are the kind of the military presence in Rome. He basically bribes them to support him. And then there's nothing that the Senate can do.
他是莉薇娅的孙子。莉薇娅嫁给了奥古斯都，看过《我，克劳狄乌斯》的观众都会记得，她被塑造成了一个残暴的太后。所以克劳狄乌斯急忙跑去控制了禁卫军——也就是罗马的军事力量。禁卫军，也就是罗马的军事力量。他基本上通过行贿让他们支持自己。然后元老院就无能为力了。
And the people want an emperor, but essentially because the emperor guarantees them bread and circuses. Right. The famous comment by Juvenal writing a few decades later. But essentially, it does sum it up. The role of the emperor is to ensure that this vast, teeming city of a million people gets fed. And they're able to do that because they have control of Egypt, the breadbasket of the Mediterranean world and of North Africa. And Claudius and then Nero build a massive deep sea
而老百姓想要一个皇帝，主要是因为皇帝能保证他们的面包和马戏。对，这是几十年后尤维纳利斯留下的名言。但本质上，这确实总结了核心：皇帝的职责是确保这座拥有一百万人口的巨大而熙攘的城市有饭吃。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们控制了埃及——地中海世界的粮仓，以及北非。因此，克劳狄乌斯以及后来的尼禄在台伯河口的奥斯蒂亚修建了一个庞大的深水
port in the mouth of the Tiber at Ostia. And they build huge granaries that line the 16 miles of the river Tiber from Ostia up to central Rome. And they essentially ensure that people don't starve. And that's the basis of the Praetorians, the bread ration, and then the ability of emperors to entertain the masses as well. And there are huge numbers of entertainments. Yeah. All of these things mean that, you know, the rule of the Caesars is vastly more popular than having a load of, you know, virtue signaling senators doing it.
港。他们修建了巨大的粮仓，沿着从奥斯蒂亚一直延伸到罗马市中心的16英里台伯河岸排列。他们基本上确保了人民不会挨饿。这就是禁卫军存在的基础、面包配给的基础，也是皇帝们能够取悦大众的基础。当时有大量的娱乐活动。是的。所有这些都意味着，恺斯们的统治远比让一群尸位素餐的元老在那里搞美德信号标榜要受欢迎得多。
Okay. But so has Nero been trained for this? I mean, has he, 16 years old, has anybody? So he's not Claudius. Claudius has a son, Britannicus, right? Now, how can Britannicus, I know Britannicus is younger, but how come people don't say, well, Britannicus is obviously, you know, he may be younger, but he's, is it because Nero's mum, and here I may be either betraying my own sort of prejudice or the influence of the
好吧。但是，尼禄接受过这方面的训练吗？我是说，他才16岁，有人接受过吗？所以他不是克劳狄乌斯。克劳狄乌斯有一个儿子，不列颠尼库斯，对吧？现在，不列颠尼库斯——我知道不列颠尼库斯年龄更小，但为什么人们不会说“不列颠尼库斯显然是——你知道的，他可能更年轻，但他才是……”是因为尼禄的妈妈——在这里我可能暴露了自己的偏见，或者是受到了史料的影响——是因为尼禄的妈妈阿格里皮娜是个类似麦克白夫人的角色，为她儿子铺平了道路？还是仅仅因为尼禄年龄更大、更有才华？又或者因为阿格里皮娜是日耳曼尼库斯的女儿？日耳曼尼库斯是罗马人民心中那位伟大的失落英雄、伟大的失落偶像，是一位在提比略统治初期英年早逝的勇猛将领。
sources, is it because Nero's mum Agrippina is this sort of Lady Macbeth figure who has prepared the ground for her son or is it that just Nero is older or more talented or Agrippina is the daughter of Germanicus who is the kind of the the great lost hero the great lost idol of the Roman people a a dashing general who dies early in the reign of Tiberius. And it's widely thought that he's been murdered. And he's commemorated as the kind of, you know, the sweetheart of the Roman masses, this man of great charisma and potential.
人们普遍认为他是被谋杀的。他被纪念为罗马群众心中的“白月光”，是一个极具个人魅力和潜力的男人。
Agrippina is his daughter. She's Caligula's sister. Caligula's sister, yeah. And she's been exiled by Caligula for being part of a conspiracy against him, gets brought back under Claudius who marries her. Because she has this blood relationship to Germanicus, she's cherished by the Roman people, but she's also more saliently cherished by the Roman army, by the military. And so that makes her a very potent player in her own right. Women are not supposed to exercise political power in Rome, but Agrippina is a significant player. And she is able to provide Claudius, who is quite elderly, because her son is that much older than Britannicus, Claudius' son by a previous wife, Nero essentially kind of provides a guarantee
阿格里皮娜是他的女儿。她是卡利古拉的姐姐。卡利古拉的姐姐，是的。她曾因参与反对卡利古拉的阴谋而被流放，但在克劳狄乌斯统治时期被接了回来，克劳狄乌斯娶了她。正因为她与日耳曼尼库斯有这种血缘关系，她受到了罗马人民的珍视，更重要的是，她受到了罗马军队、军方的珍视。这使得她本身就成了一个极具影响力的政治玩家。在罗马，女性本不该行使政治权力，但阿格里皮娜是个举足轻重的角色。她能够为年事已高的克劳狄乌斯提供保障——因为她的儿子比克劳狄乌斯前妻所生的儿子不列颠尼库斯要大得多，尼禄基本上提供了一种保障：
that if Claudius dies, there'll be someone old enough to step into his shoes. But isn't Claudius smart enough to see that that poses a threat to his own son? I mean, you would think that would occur to him. Well, that's very much the sense you get from my Claudius. But I think that, you know, Claudius adopts Nero, and so Nero therefore becomes his son.
如果克劳狄乌斯去世，会有一个足够大的人能够接替他的位置。但克劳狄乌斯难道不够聪明，看不出这对他自己的儿子构成了威胁吗？我是说，你本以为他会意识到这一点的。嗯，这正是你在《我，克劳狄乌斯》里能感受到的。但我认为，克劳狄乌斯收养了尼禄，因此尼禄就成了他的儿子。
And I think... Yeah, strange. Yeah, I mean, it does seem strange, but Claudius is anxious to establish the succession. And that's why he's married Agrippina. Now, the brilliant thing about the way that this gets presented is that subsequent historians of whom Suetonius, the biographer, is by far the biggest bitch. So he reports that Nero was always going to turn out bad,
而且我认为……是的，很奇怪。是的，我是说，这确实显得很奇怪，但克劳狄乌斯急于稳固继承人。这就是他娶了阿格里皮娜的原因。现在，这种事情被呈现出来的方式绝妙之处在于，后来的历史学家——其中传记作家苏埃托尼乌斯绝对是最毒舌的一个。因此他报道说，尼禄注定会变坏，
both because Agrippina is a kind of terrible shrew and harridan. She's a woman who wants to exercise power. So of course she's monstrous. I mean, what could be more appalling than that? But also because Nero's father, who is a descendant of the Henobarbi, kind of ancient family,
一方面是因为阿格里皮娜是个可怕的泼妇和悍妇。她是一个渴望行使权力的女人。所以她当然是个怪物。我是说，还有什么比这更骇人听闻的呢？但另一方面也是因为尼禄的父亲——作为阿诺巴比家族（Henobarbi）的后代，这是一个古老的家族——
is absolutely an appalling man. And Suetonius says of him that he's a man detestable in every way it was possible to be detestable so it's very good at this sort of stuff so in modern terms according to satonius nero's father basically kind of kills a waiter during a bullingdon club style drinking game we've all done that he knocks down a child while driving a sports car okay that's bad um he is um he maims a businessman in a pub brawl he defrauds a bank he cheats a sports star and then as minister of sport he legislates against cheating sports stars so that's what he would be in a kind of modern modern situation so he's seen as a kind of monstrous appalling person yeah um how far back you know to what extent this is kind of backdated because people want to blacken Nero's reputation, we don't really know.
绝对是一个可怕的男人。苏埃托尼乌斯评价他是一个在所有可能令人厌恶的方面都令人厌恶的人。所以他很擅长写这种东西。因此用现代的话说，根据苏埃托尼乌斯的说法，尼禄的父亲基本上在布灵顿俱乐部风格的饮酒游戏中杀死了一个服务员——我们都干过这事；他在开跑车时撞死了一个小孩——好吧，这很糟糕；嗯，他在酒吧斗殴中致残了一个商人；他诈骗了一家银行；他欺骗了一位体育明星，然后作为体育大臣，他立法反对欺骗体育明星的行径——这就是他在现代情境下会做的事。所以他被视为一个怪物般的、可怕的人。是的。这种说法有多大程度上——
But there is a sense that the Ahenobabi, the family that Nero is descended from, are seen as kind of arrogant and aggressive. And that then fuses with Agrippina's perceived kind of virago-esque qualities means that people are able to cast Nero as someone who was kind of rotten right from the beginning. Let me just interrupt you here, because obviously Nero and his mother, now I had Suetonius, I think, when I was about 11 or 12, and I can remember reading it in my grandparents' house and thinking-
在多大程度上是因为人们想要抹黑尼禄的名誉而被事后追溯的，我们其实并不知道。但确实有一种普遍看法认为，阿诺巴比家族——也就是尼禄的家族——被视为傲慢且极具攻击性的。这种特质与阿格里皮娜身上那种众所周知的女杰特质融合在一起，使得人们能够把尼禄塑造成一个从一开始就烂透了的人。我在这里打断你一下，因为显然尼禄和他的母亲——我大概在11、12岁的时候就读过苏埃托尼乌斯的书，我还记得我在祖父母家里读的时候觉得——
Lots of asterisks. And thinking, well, I'm getting away with- Lots of it's blacked out. I'm getting away with this. But if this was anything but a Penguin classic, it would be in the bin and I'd be thrown out in the cold in deep disgrace. Because aren't the scenes, I'm trying to remember this,
里面有很多星号。觉得，哇，我这可是在逃过一劫——里面很多内容都被涂黑了。我这可是在蒙混过关。但如果这不是企鹅经典文库，这本书早就被扔进垃圾桶，而我也会因为深陷耻辱而被赶出家门了。因为难道那些场景——我正努力回想这一点——
but aren't the scenes where he and his mum are in a litter and he gets out and there's kind of semen stains all over his clothes because he and his mum have been up to no good. So this stuff is all, I mean, this is all just totally invented, right? This is just the formula of a kind of Roman invective. You're having incest and because it's almost sort of the kind of thing that Ptolemies would have done, I suppose. Well, essentially Nero, when he becomes emperor and there is, of course, inevitably a rumor that Claudius is poisoned.
难道那些场景不是讲他和母亲坐在一辆轿子里，他下了车，衣服上到处都是精斑，因为他和母亲一直在干见不得人的勾当吗？所以这些东西全都是——我是说，这些全都是凭空捏造的对吧？这只是一种罗马式谩骂的套路。里面有乱伦元素，而且几乎有点像是托勒密王朝会干的那种事，我想。嗯，基本上当尼禄成为皇帝时，必然会出现一种传闻，说克劳狄乌斯是被毒死的。
He's supposed to have been poisoned with mushrooms. And it's absolutely the convention that powerful women go around poisoning people. So this is the stuff that's told about Livia, Augustus's wife, and it's told about Agrippina as well. But they probably didn't. Is that your claim, basically? We don't know. I mean, how do we know? We can't know. There are certain things we just have to accept we don't know. You've written books about this. If you don't know, nobody does. What I know is that we don't know. We don't know. But what i know is that we don't know we don't know but what i also know is that these rumors were believed and they were believed because the power politics in the in the augustan house was incredibly carnivorous um and and perhaps you know if
据说他是被蘑菇毒死的。而强大的女性四处下毒绝对是一个固有套路。所以关于奥古斯都的妻子莉薇娅有这样的传说，关于阿格里皮娜也有这样的传说。但她们大概根本没这么做。这基本上就是你的观点吗？我们不知道。我是说，我们怎么知道？我们无从得知。有些事情我们只能承认自己无从得知。你写过关于这方面的书。如果你都不知道，那就没人知道了。我所知道的就是我们无从得知。我们无从得知。但我所知道的是，这些谣言当时确实有人信，它们之所以被相信，是因为奥古斯都家族内部的权力政治极其残酷血腥。
you wanted to argue that agrippina had poisoned claudius it's because young britannicus is about to come of age and so therefore if nero is going to become emperor, she needs to get him in position very quickly. And it's possible that Nero is aware of the debt that he owes his mother, that without her, he simply wouldn't be in the position that he is. And to begin with, there are all kinds of coins, all kinds of statues, all kinds of propaganda,
也许如果你想争辩说是阿格里皮娜毒死了克劳狄乌斯，那是因为年轻的不列颠尼库斯即将成年，所以如果尼禄要成为皇帝，她必须非常迅速地让他上位。并且，尼禄有可能意识到他对他母亲的亏欠——没有她，他根本不可能处于现在的地位。在最初几年里，有各种各样的硬币、各种各样的雕像、各种各样的宣传，
proclaiming the amity between mother and son. As the years go by, so Agrippina starts to vanish from the coins and from the statues until by the end, Nero is incredibly keen to get rid of her. And I think that there is one of the things that runs throughout the stories that are told about Nero, and I think must kind of be true to his character, is a fondness for shocking, a kind of fondness for pushing things to the extreme. And so there's a kind of cross between Trump and Chris Morris. Right.
都在宣扬母子之间的和谐美满。但随着时间的推移，阿格里皮娜开始从硬币和雕像上消失，直到最后，尼禄极其渴望摆脱她。我认为，贯穿所有关于尼禄的故事中的一个主题——并且一定在某种程度上符合他的性格特征——就是他对震惊世人的喜爱，一种将事情推向极致的爱好。所以他有点像是特朗普和克里斯·莫里斯的结合体。对。
Okay. So he'd be on his own Channel 4 kind of semi-satirical show he he enjoys shocking people and and kind of trampling on the expectations of and his little elites but at the same time he's very shrewd and and the kind of cruel quality to his his very sharp intelligent satirical mind and so one of the things that he does is, I think he's supposed to have kept a woman who looks like his mother. And he kind of fondles her and caresses her. And obviously this is intended to be completely shocking.
好吧。所以他会在第四频道搞那种半讽刺的个人秀。他喜欢震惊世人，喜欢践踏他的小精英们的期望，但与此同时他又非常精明，其锐利、聪明、讽刺的头脑中带有一种残忍的特质。所以他做过的事之一，就是据说他养了一个长得像他母亲的女人。他会抚摸她、爱抚她。显然，这完全是为了达到令人震惊的效果。
And then in due course, he murders her. And the stories that are told about the process of murder are very, very kind of flamboyant and baroque. So he's meant to have arranged for for her bedroom to fall in on her he kind of sets in a roof that you pull a lever and it falls down and crushes her that doesn't work that's very bond villain it's very very bond villain and even more bond villain he gives her a yacht that goes out into the bay of naples again they pull a lever it disintegrates but agrippina can swim so she comes to to the shore. And so Nero, fed up by this
然后不久之后，他就谋杀了她。关于谋杀过程的故事非常、非常华丽且具有巴洛克风格。据说他曾安排她的卧室在她头上坍塌——他设计了一个屋顶，只要拉一下杠杆，屋顶就会塌下来把她压死。这招没成功。这非常像邦德反派的作风。这非常、非常像邦德反派，而且更像邦德反派的是，他送给她一艘游艇，驶入那不勒斯湾，同样是拉一下杠杆，游艇就会解体，但阿格里皮娜会游泳，所以她游回了岸边。
point, just sends a posse of guards who kind of stab her to death. Now, it's not, I think, shocking that a member of the Augustan house would kill another member of his house. There's quite a lot of this going on, but it's done discreetly. Yeah, this is so theatrical, isn't it? This is so theatrical. It's so kind of public. And when Nero has finished it, she's murdered on the Bay of Naples. He returns to Rome and it's like he's celebrating a triumph when he goes into Rome.
因此尼禄到这个时候已经彻底厌烦了，直接派了一队卫兵把她乱刀刺死。我认为，奥古斯都家族的成员杀死自己家族的另一个成员并不令人震惊，这种事发生得挺多的，但通常都是秘密进行的。是的，这太具有戏剧性了，不是吗？这太具戏剧性了。这太公开了。当尼禄完成这一切——她是在那不勒斯湾被谋杀的——他回到罗马时，进入罗马的场面就像是在庆祝凯旋。
And when in due course, he takes to the stage, which is again, kind of shocking thing for a Roman to do, let alone an emperor, because actors, the Romans regard actors as being absolutely kind of the
当他不久后登台表演时——这对于一个罗马人来说已经是极其令人震惊的事了，更不用说是一个皇帝了，因为罗马人将演员视为绝对的
lowest of the low. They're on a level with prostitutes and madams and all kinds of things like that. So for Nero to do that is very shocking. But among the roles that he plays are figures from Greek tragedy who are famous for having killed their mothers. And I suppose the most famous is Orestes, who is the son of Agamemnon and Clytemnestra. Clytemnestra kills Agamemnon, the returning king from the Trojan War. And Orestes is then told by the Delphic Oracle to kill his mother. And so he's torn between his natural love as a son and the dictates of the god and goes ahead and does it and gets pursued by the furies of these kind of terrifying gods. But he's done it essentially because the gods called him to do it. And so Nero is casting his murder of his mother in that kind of way. And basically what Nero is doing is he is casting himself as the equivalent of a hero
社会底层。他们的地位和妓女、老鸨以及诸如此类的人不相上下。所以尼禄去当演员是极其令人震惊的。但他扮演的角色包括希腊悲剧中那些因杀害母亲而闻名的人物。我想其中最著名的就是俄瑞斯忒斯，他是阿伽门农和克吕泰涅斯特拉的儿子。克吕泰涅斯特拉杀死了从特洛伊战争归来的国王丈夫阿伽门农，然后德尔斐神谕命令俄瑞斯忒斯去杀死他的母亲。于是他在作为儿子的天伦之爱与神的旨意之间备受煎熬，最终还是去做了，随后遭到了复仇女神——也就是那些恐怖的神明——的追杀。但他这么做主要是因为神召唤他这么做。所以尼禄把对母亲的谋杀包装成了那种性质。基本上，尼禄是在把自己塑造为
from Greek tragedy. So a hero, it's not quite the meaning that it has for us. A hero is someone who stands between humans and gods and who perform outsized deeds and do terrible things and terrible things are done to them. And Nero basically is using all the resources of drama and of song and of his own life to portray himself as someone sprung from the ancient world of Greek tragedy. And that is what makes him so disorienting and destabilizing, I think, is because we talk about him being, what's the reality behind the myth? Well, the reality behind the myth is he's creating the myth. But okay, Tom, I mean, all of this raises so many interesting questions because obviously he's a performer, he's a populist and all this stuff.
希腊悲剧中的英雄的化身。英雄，这跟我们现在的理解不太一样。英雄是那种介于人类与神明之间、做出超凡壮举、干下可怕勾当、同时也遭受可怕命运的人。尼禄基本上是利用了戏剧、歌唱以及自己生命中的所有资源，把自己塑造成一个脱胎于希腊悲剧古老世界的人。我认为，正是这一点让他如此令人迷失方向和感到动摇。我们总在讨论他究竟如何，神话背后的现实是什么？好吧，神话背后的现实就是：他正在亲手创造这个神话。但好吧，汤姆，我的意思是，所有这些都引发了如此多的有趣问题，因为显然他是个表演者、民粹主义者，还有诸如此类的一切。
But the one thing that interests me as somebody who does more modern history is you and people who write about Nero are basing this on, I mean, how many written sources are there? Three, four, five? No, it's more than that. And you've got the evidence of coins
但作为一个研究更现代历史的人，我感兴趣的是——你和那些撰写尼禄历史的人是基于什么来写的？我是说，现存的文字史料有多少？三篇、四篇、五篇？不，不止这些。你还有硬币和考古学的证据。
and of archaeology. Yeah, but put the coins on one side. I mean, the you something but some of the stories for example the death of agrippina and the yacht you know the yacht falling apart or his carry-on with eunuchs or kicking his wife to death or the other sort of canonical things that we know about him they are often based on on a couple of sources aren't they at heart and how far do you when you're writing this because you've obviously written about Nero I mean you love Nero and you've written about it with such sort of enthusiasm and and and brio but how much when you're writing it do you think to yourself well yeah this could well be bollocks yeah I'm gonna write but i'm gonna tell the story anyway well i it's it's a constant challenge and the more grotesque the stories the more the challenge is there but
是的，但先别管硬币。我是说，有些故事——例如阿格里皮娜的死和游艇事件，你知道的，游艇解体，或者他跟阉人胡混，或者把妻子踢死，以及我们所知道的关于他的其他一些经典事件——它们在本质上往往是基于寥寥几份史料，对吧？当你写这些的时候——因为你显然写过尼禄，我是说你热爱尼禄，并且带着极大的热情和神采写了关于他的内容——在你写作时，有多少次你会心想：“好吧，这特么很可能是胡扯，但我还是要写，我无论如何都要讲这个故事”？嗯，这确实是一个不断的挑战，故事越荒诞，挑战就越大。但我认为，对于尼禄来说，
i think that that with nero um there is extraneous evidence that um in a sense Nero is kind of writing scripts for himself and creating stage sets for himself that mean that in a sense a lot of the kind of more hostile stories that are told about him are distorted refractions of things that he himself was trying to do. So essentially what you have to do is to look at the entire mass of the evidence, and that goes beyond the simply textual evidence, and essentially try and work out, well, are these stories simply fantasy? Or are they true? And was he mad? Or are they refractions of something that might conceivably
存在着外部证据，从某种意义上说，尼禄其实是在为自己编写剧本、为自己搭建舞台布景。这意味着，从某种程度上讲，许多针对他的充满敌意的故事，其实是对他自己试图去做的那些事情的歪曲折射。所以你基本上必须做的是，审视全部的证据——这不仅仅局限于文本证据——然后试着弄清楚：这些故事究竟纯粹是幻想？还是真实发生的？他是个疯子吗？还是说这些只是可能源自尼禄本人的某些行为的折射？如果我们能理解他在做什么，也许我们就能领会他的全部意义所在。汤姆，他当时疯了吗？
come from Nero himself? And if we can understand what it is that he's doing, perhaps we can then get a sense of what he's all about. And was he mad, Tom? No, he's not mad. He's a man of ferocious creative ability and talent. Yeah, he reminds me of the Joker, the Joker in the Heath Ledger iteration. Well, when I was translating The Life of Suetonius,
不，他没疯。他是一个拥有凶猛创造力和才华的人。是的，他让我想起小丑，希斯·莱杰饰演的那版小丑。好吧，当我翻译苏埃托尼乌斯的《传记》时，
he describes how Nero as a young man would go out into the streets and he'd kind of disguise himself as a slave and just go out and kind of beat people up and enjoy it. And I did kind of have this image of perhaps of casting Seneca as a Batman figure roaming the streets of Rome, fighting. But yes, I think that the Joker would be the closest analogy in contemporary culture to kind of what Nero is doing. He is malevolent, I think, and sinister, but also incredibly charismatic and incredibly creative. And the thing that, you know, the Christopher Biggins portrayal of him in I, Claudius,
他描述了尼禄年轻时如何走上街头，把自己伪装成奴隶，然后四处殴打路人并以此为乐。我当时确实脑补了这样一幅画面：或许可以把塞涅卡选角为蝙蝠侠式的角色，在罗马街头游荡、行侠仗义。不过是的，我觉得在当代文化中最接近尼禄所作所为的类比就是小丑。我认为他既有恶毒和阴险的一面，但同时也极具个人魅力和创造力。我想，克里斯托弗·比金斯在《我，克劳狄乌斯》中对他的塑造，
and indeed in the Heineken advert, if you, I don't know if you remember. I don't remember. I kind of look that up. It's really, you know, Christopher Biggins as Nero is, he's sentenced so many gladiators to death that he can't move his thumb.
以及在喜力啤酒广告中的形象——如果你，我不知道你记不记得的话。我不记得了。我得去查查。真的，克里斯托弗·比金斯饰演的尼禄，他判处了太多角斗士死刑，以至于他的大拇指都动不了了。
So they bring on a glass of Heineken and he drinks it and then he's able to start sentencing gladiators to death that he can't move his thumb so they bring on a glass of wine and he drinks it and then he he's able to start sentencing gladiators to death again but also with peter ustinov in cuivades that that he's this kind of fat comic he's well he's kind of murderous billy bunter right you know yeah great love um that's untrue i think i think nero is not a kind of ridiculous figure and i think also that the the stories that get told about him, that he was a terrible singer, that he was a terrible actor, that he was a terrible charioteer. These are not true either. He was clearly very proficient at all of them. Because to do all of them required an absolute kind of baseline of talent. And so the parallel would be, imagine a world leader today, starring in, you know, an Oscar winning Hollywood film, headlining at Glastonbury, competing in Formula
于是他们端上一杯喜力啤酒，他喝了下去，然后他又可以开始判处角斗士死刑了——以至于他的大拇指都动不了了，于是他们端上一杯酒，他喝了下去，然后他又可以开始判处角斗士死刑了——还有彼得·乌斯蒂诺夫在《暴君焚城录》里演的那个胖乎乎的小丑式人物，好吧，他就像是个充满杀戮欲的比利·班特（Billy Bunter），对吧？你知道的，大肆搜刮。那是不真实的，我认为尼禄绝不是一个荒谬可笑的人物。而且我认为，关于他的那些传闻——说他是个糟糕的歌手、糟糕的演员、糟糕的御者——这些也同样不是真的。他在所有这些领域显然都非常精通。因为要精通所有这些，本身就需要绝对的基准才华。所以这可以类比为：想象一下今天的某位世界领导人，既主演了一部获得奥斯卡奖的好莱坞电影，又在格拉斯本音乐节上担任压轴演出，还参加了F1赛车比赛。即使是最残酷的独裁者要做到这一点，你也必须具备某种基准的才华才能蒙混过关。因为我们知道，尽管当时确实有人对此冷嘲热讽，但也有人对尼禄的所作所为充满敬意。当尼禄死后，各种猫王风格的模仿者在他死后雨后春笋般冒出来——这本身就表明他确实在某种程度上拥有巨大的受欢迎度——
One. Even the most kind of brutal autocrat to do that, you'd have to have a certain baseline of talent to get away with it. Because we know that although there were people who did kind of sneer at this there were also people who regarded Nero with great admiration for what he had done and when Nero dies and kind of you know Elvis style impersonators pop up all over the place after he's dead which in itself is an indication that he you know there was kind of huge degree of popularity um what marks them out is that they have immense musical proficiency so he's a he's he's i think a very very talented talented man and that's kind of what makes him frightening brilliant well let's take a break here and then we can come back we can set rome on fire talk about the christians and do lots of questions
而这些模仿者的共同特征就是他们拥有极高的音乐造诣。所以我觉得他是一个非常、非常有才华的人，而这正是他令人感到可怕的地方。太精彩了。好吧，我们在这里休息一下，然后回来放火烧罗马，聊聊基督徒，并回答一大堆问题，
because we have tons of questions to get through. All right, see you in a second. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
因为我们有成堆的问题要处理。好的，一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定阵营。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history tom holland is pronouncing on nero one of his favorite subjects and i am just really along for the ride. We have got lots of questions, Tom, and I think we should just go straight in, because that way we can cover the subjects we haven't already done. So Ben Crowden, he says, what happened to Britannicus? So this is Claudius's son, who you might say ought to have been emperor. Maybe you can say whether
告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，汤姆·霍兰德正在评说尼禄——他最喜欢的主题之一，而我只是顺便搭个伴而已。汤姆，我们有很多问题，我觉得我们应该直接切入正题，这样我们就能涵盖那些我们还没来得及讨论的主题。本·克劳登（Ben Crowden）问：不列颠尼库斯怎么了？所以这是克劳狄乌斯的儿子，按理说你可能会觉得他才应该是皇帝。也许你可以说说
you think Britannicus was robbed or whatever, but what happened to him? Did Nero kill him? And how different might things have been if he descended to the throne? And that raises an interesting question about how much Nero's bad behaviour is actually a consequence of the role
你觉得不列颠尼库斯是不是被剥夺了继承权之类的事情，但究竟发生了什么？尼禄杀了他吗？如果是不列颠尼库斯登上王位，情况会有多大不同？这也引发了一个有趣的问题：尼禄的糟糕行为，实际上究竟是这个皇权角色带来的后果，还是他本人的问题？是“元首”这种制度本身的性质，导致年轻人在拥有那种权威时行为变得败坏吗？总之，请讲，关于不列颠尼库斯。所以不列颠尼库斯，在尼禄成为皇帝之后，据说是在一次宴会上食物中毒身亡。无可避免地，朱利安-克劳狄家族中任何在宴会上食物中毒死去的人，
rather than the man, whether it was the nature of the princeps meant that young men behaved badly when they had that sort of authority. Anyway, go ahead, Britannicus. So Britannicus, after Nero has become emperor, he dies supposedly of food poisoning at a banquet. And inevitably anyone in the Julia-Claudia family who dies of food poisoning at a banquet,
人们都会怀疑是毒药起了作用。而且毫无疑问，尼禄和不列颠尼库斯之间的关系似乎并不好。不列颠尼库斯一直管尼禄叫“阿诺巴比”（Ahenobarbus），用的是他以前的姓氏——虽然因为被克劳狄乌斯收养，这已经不再是他的姓了，但尼禄把这视为一种轻蔑。还有一个非常令人不快的传闻说，
you know, there are suspicions that the poison has operated and um there's there's no question the relations between nero and britannicus don't seem to have been great britannicus kept calling nero um uh ahenobarbus after his um which was no longer his name because he'd been adopted by claudius so nero took that as a slight um there's a very unpleasant story that um nero sodomizes him not not not because he he particularly wanted to but as a way of kind of establishing his dominance and humiliating britannicus so that's the kind of unpleasant story and then the story about the poisoning is that um he employs this specialist called Lucaster who brews up poison. And it's kind of too slow operating. And Nero says, you know, make it more powerful. And they try it out on a pig and the pig immediately dies. And so Nero says, that's great. And Britannicus dies
尼禄鸡奸了不列颠尼库斯——倒不是因为他有多想要，而是作为一种建立统治地位和羞辱不列颠尼库斯的方式。所以这是一个相当令人不快的传闻。接着关于下毒的故事是，他雇佣了一个名叫卢卡斯特（Lucaster）的制毒专家来熬制毒药。结果毒药发作得太慢了，尼禄就说：“把它弄得更强效一点。”他们拿一头猪做实验，猪立刻就死了。于是尼禄说：“太棒了。”接着不列颠尼库斯就死了，
and gets burned the next day on a pyre and gets kind of rushed off to, you know, gets buried very fast. And Nero is so thrilled that he basically sets Lucasterre and gets kind of rushed off to, you know, gets buried very fast. And Nero's so thrilled that he basically sets Lucaster up as a kind of poisoning tutor. So, you know, he supposedly sends people off to study with Lucaster. I mean, all of this is, I mean, you know, this is all, this is all bad. But, you know, Britannicus is in the way he yeah he dies i
第二天就在火葬堆上被火化，急匆匆地下葬了。尼禄兴奋得甚至把卢卡斯特安排成了一个“下毒导师”，据说他把一些人派去跟卢卡斯特学习。我是说，所有这些——我是说，这些全都太糟糕了。但无论如何，不列颠尼库斯挡了路，所以他就死了。
you know i would i would say that there was motive and opportunity there so you could argue couldn't you i mean going back to my point about the nature of the role you could argue that nero would have been mad to allow britannicus to live that actually absolutely it's sort of bad luck you know but britannicus has to go it's kind of in the way. Also, a wonderful detail in the Septimius, that Nero kills Britannicus less because he's a threat, actually, than because he has a better singing voice than Nero. So, again, that's kind of a classic example of the way that, you know... It's very Noel and Liam Gallagher, that particular dynamic, isn't it?
你知道的，我会说那里有动机和机会，所以你可以辩论，不是吗？我的意思是，回到我关于角色性质的观点，你可以辩论说，尼禄如果不让布里塔尼库斯活下来，就会是个疯子，实际上，完全是这样，这有点像运气不好，你知道的，但布里塔尼库斯必须走人，他有点碍事。此外，《塞普ティミ乌斯》中有一个精彩的细节，尼禄杀害布里塔尼库斯与其说是因为他是个威胁，不如说是因为他的歌声比尼禄更好听。所以，再次说明，这可以说是这种现象的一个经典例子……那种特定的动态非常像诺尔和利亚姆·加拉格尔，不是吗？
Yes, yeah. All right, so that's Britannicus. Now let's move on to a crucial question. David Banks, was Nero the most powerful ginger of all time? I think ginger, I'm assuming that's not a misprint and he hasn't written Singer. No, I think it's ginger. It is ginger.
是的，没错。好吧，那这就是布里塔尼库斯。现在让我们转到一个关键问题。大卫·班克斯，尼禄是有史以来最厉害的红发人吗？我想红发，我假设这不是印刷错误，他写的不是歌手。不，我想这就是红发。这就是红发。
We've got one from Lizzie Harrington, haven't we? Oh, yes. Is the hair colour based on evidence of statues or descriptions in documents or merely because prejudice that people assume that this kind of bad behaviour could only come from a ginger? I don't know, Tom, was Nero definitely ginger haired? Well, so it comes from, again, his family name, Henabarbus, which basically means bronze beard. And this is an ancient legend that the ancestor of the Henabarbi, he's coming back from, he's riding to Rome while a great battle is being fought. He doesn't know what the result of the henna barbie is uh he's he's coming back from um he's riding to rome while a great battle
我们收到了来自莉齐·哈灵顿的一条，对吧？哦，是的。发色是基于雕像的证据，还是文献中的描述，亦或是仅仅因为人们带有偏见，认为这种恶劣的行为只能出自一个红发人之手？我不知道，汤姆，尼禄绝对是红发吗？嗯，所以这再次源于他的家族名“赫纳巴布斯”，基本上意思是铜须。这是一个古老的传说，赫纳巴布斯的祖先，他正从……他正骑马赶回罗马，而此时一场大战正在进行。他不知道赫纳巴布斯的结果是……嗯，他正从……嗯，他正骑马赶回罗马，而此时一场大战
is being fought he doesn't know what the result of the battle is castor and pollux um the uh the divine twins gemini appear to him and say that the romans have won the battle and then they stroke his beard which turns bronze so a kind of gingery and so supposedly um all the henna barbie from that point on have a ginger beard and so that's presumably why nero is portrayed as having a ginger beard although actually satonia says that his hair was was light blonde so all right yeah a bit of you know we don't know we don't yeah so he's more like the we were doing the game of thrones podcast we talked about jack gleason who was joffrey he's more joffrey isn't he i mean that's kind of the that's how i imagine him because
正在进行，他不知道战果如何。卡斯托耳和波吕克斯，嗯，卡斯托耳和波吕克斯，嗯，那对神圣的孪生兄弟双子座出现在他面前，告诉他罗马人赢了这场大战，然后他们抚摸他的胡须，胡须变成了铜色，也就是一种带点红的颜色。因此，据说从那时起，所有的赫纳巴布斯族人都有红胡子，所以这大概就是为什么尼禄被描绘成拥有红胡子，尽管实际上苏埃托尼乌斯说他的头发是浅金色的。所以，好吧，是的，有点……你知道的，我们并不知道，我们并不——是的，所以他更像是我们在做《权力的游戏》播客时谈到的杰克·格里森，也就是扮演乔弗里的那个演员，他更像是乔弗里，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是——这就是我想象中的他，因为
joffrey in game of thrones is this very sort of yeah and just his general demeanor he's more Joffrey isn't he I mean that's kind of the that's how I imagine him because Joffrey in Game of Thrones is this very sort of yeah and just his general demeanor he's a sort of willful child who is cruel and capricious and all that sort of stuff I mean that's kind of what Nero is on the Joffrey level you don't think he's as bad as that well I'll tell you so one of the things one of the things about Nero is that um he's actually very uxorious so Joffrey of course I mean he you know he goes around killing everyone yeah but but i mean you say he's luxurious but i mean i mean i imagine you're very luxurious but you've never kicked your wife to death which we don't know that nero did so nero marries claudius his daughter so effectively he's marrying his sister you didn't with your ptolemies you didn't
《权力的游戏》里的乔弗里就是那种非常……是的，单从他的总体举止来看，他更像是乔弗里，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是——这就是我想象中的他，因为《权力的游戏》里的乔弗里就是那种非常……是的，单从他的总体举止来看，他是一个有点任性、残酷、反复无常的孩子，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，尼禄在乔弗里的水平上基本上就是这样。你不觉得他有那么坏吗？好吧，我告诉你，关于尼禄的一件事是，嗯，他对妻子非常百依百顺。所以乔弗里当然——我的意思是，他到处杀人——是的。但我的意思是，你说他对妻子百依百顺，但我的意思是——我的意思是，我猜你对妻子也非常百依百顺，但你从来没有把你的妻子踢死过。不过我们并不知道尼禄真的这么做过。所以尼禄娶了克劳迪斯的女儿，也就是实际上他娶了自己的姐姐。你没有，如果是你们托勒密王朝，你可不会
you'd enjoy that yeah he doesn't he doesn't like octavia um his first great love is a Syrian freedwoman called Actae, who he's passionately devoted to. Agrippina, one of the things that comes between him and Agrippina is Agrippina doesn't approve of this, doesn't want a freedwoman as a daughter-in-law. So an ex-slave, freedwoman. An ex-slave, yeah. So Nero basically kind of splits up with her, but is always fond of her. And when Nero dies, it's Actae who buries him. He then falls in love with Poppaea Sabina, who we've talked about already in the Eunuch episode. But she's the most fashionable woman in Rome.
你会喜欢那样的。是的，他不喜欢屋大维亚。他的第一个挚爱是一个名叫阿克泰的叙利亚被释奴女，他对其倾注了炽热的爱。阿格里皮娜，在他和阿格里皮娜之间产生隔阂的事情之一就是阿格里皮娜不赞成这一点，不希望一个被释奴女当儿媳妇。所以是一个前奴隶，被释奴女。一个前奴隶，是的。所以尼禄基本上和她分开了，但对她一直很好。而当尼禄死时，正是阿克泰埋葬了他。接着他爱上了波帕埃娅·萨比娜，我们在太监那一集中已经谈过她了。但她是罗马最时髦的女人。
She bathes in asses milk. She has her own cosmetics range. She says, I hope I die before I get old. Years before Roger Daltrey and Pete Townsend did. And her wish comes true because she dies in childbirth. And the story is that Nero kicked her to death. But we don't know that. We don't know that. How can we know that? Again, it's the kind of malevolent story that would be told about him by his enemies. But we know that Nero was devoted to her because he deifies her he lavishes um a year's worth of of incense from Arabia at her funeral and of course he um he
她用驴奶洗澡。她有自己的化妆品系列。她说：“我希望我在变老之前死去。”比罗杰·达尔特里和皮特·汤森早了好几年。而她的愿望成真了，因为她在分娩时死去了。传闻是尼禄把她踢死的。但我们并不知道这一点。我们并不知道。我们怎么可能知道呢？同样，这是他的敌人们会编造的关于他的恶意故事。但我们知道尼禄对她情深意切，因为他将她神圣化，他在她的葬礼上挥霍了阿拉伯产的一整年的香料，当然，他……
constructs a kind of um sterile maimed living model of her in the form of this freedman this this boy who looks exactly like her. This is Sporus, right? Yes. And we haven't had any genital mutilation in this episode yet. So here it comes. So the genitals and penis get removed and Nero offers money for someone who could make him a real woman, so properly make him a woman, implant a uterus and so on. Can't do that.
他在这个被释奴身上——这个长得跟她一模一样的男孩身上——重构了一个仿佛处于无菌状态的、残缺的、活生生的模型。这就是斯波鲁斯，对吧？是的。而我们在这一集里还没有出现过任何生殖器切除的桥段。所以它来了。于是生殖器和阴茎被切除了，尼禄悬赏寻找能把他真正变成女人的人，也就是真正彻底地把他变成女人，植入子宫等等。做不到。
But to the degree that he can, he recreates Poppaea. He does this clearly because he, you know, he's... That's a very strange... Tom, I think this is a pretty strange definition of auxorious behaviour. I mean, it's unusual behaviour even for a Roman emperor, right? It's a Neronian form of displaying his passion for his dead wife. Yes. And then he marries another woman, Statilia Messalina, who is like papaya witty sophisticated aristocratic
但在他力所能及的范围内，他重塑了波帕埃娅。他这么做显然是因为他，你知道，他……这是一个非常奇怪的……汤姆，我认为这是对百依百顺行为的一个相当奇怪的定义。我的意思是，即使对罗马皇帝来说，这也是一种不同寻常的行为，对吧？这是尼禄式的展现他对死去的妻子满腔热忱的一种方式。是的。然后他又娶了另一个女人，斯塔蒂莉娅·梅萨利娜，她就像波帕埃娅一样机智、成熟、高贵，
clearly very much um nero's type and you know he's he stays true to her even though he's also simultaneously married this this kind of um her sats papaya um yeah so he's married to this eunuch i mean that's that's staying true. It's a very loose description of staying true. I know, I know. This may be South London morality, Tom, but you wouldn't get away with this and chipping Norton. It's a Neronian form of being faithful to these three women. So Actae, Poppea and Sotilia Messalina.
显然非常符合尼禄的口味，而且你知道的，他对她始终如一，尽管他同时也娶了这个——这种类型的——她的萨特·波帕埃娅——是的，所以他娶了这个太监，我的意思是——那叫始终如一。对于始终如一这是一个非常松散的描述。我知道，我知道。这也许是南伦敦的道德观，汤姆，但在奇平诺顿你可蒙混不过去。这是对这三个女人保持忠诚的尼禄式方式。所以是阿克泰、波帕埃娅和斯塔蒂莉娅·梅萨利娜。
He's essentially devoted to the three of them. I can't quite remember how we got onto that. But anyway, basically I'm saying he's not as bad as he seemed but the way in which he shows good behavior is still terrifying conventional conventional loving husband i think that's we've got him nailed down all right let's move on stephen clark a friend of the show has a question uh who or what caused the great fire of rome whom did nero blame for it? And if I can add a twist, how is it that Nero himself came to be blamed for it and everybody thinks he fiddled
他基本上对这三个人一往情深。我有点记不清我们是怎么扯到这上面来的了。但不管怎样，我基本上是在说他没有看上去那么坏，不过他表现出良好行为的方式依然令人毛骨悚然。传统型、传统的慈爱丈夫，我想这就是我们把他的形象给钉死了吧。好吧，让我们继续，史密斯·克拉克，节目的老朋友，有一个问题：呃，是谁或什么引发了罗马大火？尼禄把这事怪在了谁头上？如果我能加一个转折的话，尼禄本人又是怎么成为被指责的对象，并且所有人都认为他在
while Rome burned? Obviously, they didn't even have fiddles. No, he's a liar. So he's talking about the lie. But that's all rubbish, isn't it? He didn't play while Rome burned. Well, so the stories are that Nero sets fire to Rome
罗马燃烧时拉小提琴的呢？显然，他们当时甚至连小提琴都没有。不，他在扯谎。所以他是在谈论这个谎言。但那全都是无稽之谈，不是吗？罗马燃烧时他并没有弹琴。嗯，所以传闻是尼禄放火烧了罗马，
basically because he's a kind of pyromaniacal Le Corbusier. He doesn't like Rome's architecture. He finds its kind of narrow, winding streets upsetting. He wants something more modern and clean. So he's a kind of murderous 1950s town planner. Yes, he's the man who made Brasil 1950s town planner yes he's the man who made brazilia yes um so so that's the story uh and the further story is that he treats burning rome as a kind of backdrop to sing about the fall of troy um is this true or probably not i mean i'd say kind of 80 percent no rome is a tinderbox it's largely made of wood um there are all kinds
基本上是因为他是一个有纵火狂倾向的勒·柯布西耶。他不喜欢罗马的建筑。他觉得罗马那种狭窄、蜿蜒的街道让人心烦。他想要更现代、更干净的东西。所以他就像是一个充满杀戮的二十世纪五十年代城市规划师。是的，他就是那个打造了巴西利亚的二十世纪五十年代城市规划师，是的，他就是那个打造了巴西利亚的人，是的，嗯——所以这就是传闻，而进一步的传闻是，他把焚烧罗马当作一种背景来歌唱特洛伊的陷落。这是真的吗？大概不是吧。我的意思是，我要说大概有百分之八十是假的。罗马是一个火药桶，基本上全是由木头建造的，
of flammable materials stored everywhere it it rages for nine days it incinerates much of the city um nero is not there when when it burns down um he comes rushing back uh as i've said he's he you know he's he's very proficient at trying to fight it. He basically behaves responsibly and well. And he does indeed rebuild Rome. I guess Le Corbusier would be the way. I mean, perhaps the kind of parallel. And so traditionists blame him, do they? Is that how it works?
到处都储存着各种易燃材料，大火肆虐了九天，烧毁了这座城市的大部分地区。尼禄在罗马被烧毁时并不在那里，他匆忙赶回——正如我所说的那样，他——你知道的，他在努力灭火方面非常在行。他基本上表现得很负责任，也做得很好。而且他的确重建了罗马。我想勒·柯布西耶就是那种风格吧。我的意思是，也许就是那种类比。那么传统主义者因此责怪他，是吗？事情是这样的吗？
Well, he then goes on to build this kind of golden house, which is this huge, it's not just the house itself, which is stunning, but he builds essentially the equivalent of a country state in the middle of Rome. So again, there's a kind of hint there as to Nero's character that he loves paradox and shock. Nothing could be more paradoxical, nothing could be more shocking than to create a country estate in the middle of the most crowded city in the world. And of course, this infuriates people whose property has been lost. You know, senators have lost property. Large numbers of the poor have lost their property. And to see Nero building this estate is, you know, I mean, of course, it kind of provokes resentment. So pretty much all our sources apart from Tacitus says that Nero did start the fire.
嗯，他随后开始建造这个所谓的金宫，这是一个巨大的——不仅仅是房子本身令人惊叹，而且他基本上在罗马市中心建造了一个等同于乡村庄园的东西。所以，这里再次暗示了尼禄的性格，那就是他喜欢悖论和震惊。没有什么比在世界上最拥挤的城市的中心建造一个乡村庄园更具悖论性、更令人震惊的了。当然，这激怒了那些失去财产的人。你知道的，元老员们失去了财产。大量穷人失去了财产。看到尼禄建造这个庄园，你知道的——我的意思是，当然，这激怒了人们。所以除了塔西陀之外，几乎所有的史料都说尼禄确实放了这把火。
Um, they essentially say he starts the fire, you know, Suetonius says, because he wants to make Rome look more beautiful, others because he wants to, to, to, to build the house. Um, is it credible? I, again, I said, I, I think not, but I think there is, you know, it's what I would say about Nero's character is that it's not entirely proven that he didn't start it. So he could have done it. He could have done. Yeah.
嗯，他们基本上说他放了这把火，你知道的，苏埃托尼乌斯说，是因为他想让罗马看起来更美丽，其他人则说是因为他想要建造那栋房子。嗯，这可信吗？我，还是那句话，我认为不可信，但我认为，你知道的，我要对尼禄性格说的是，他没有放火并没有被完全证实。所以他确实可能这么做过。他确实可能这么做过。是的。
It's not, it's kind of within the bounds, I think, of the kind of personality that Nero seems to have had. Yeah, the sort of Joker style. You might conceivably have done it. But of course, the fire is also notorious because it's the first entry of Christians. Right. So is that him? He blames the Christians
这并非——我认为这在尼禄似乎拥有的那种人格的范围内。是的，那种小丑风格。你完全可以想象他做过这种事。但当然，这场大火也臭名昭著，因为它是基督徒的首次登场。没错。所以那是他吗？他把罪责归咎于基督徒，
or is that just generally in the air and he picks up on it? Or he reflects it or whatever. So the story of Nero blaming the Christians and having them arrested and then having them put to death in very, very kind of typically neronian manner they are um soaked in pitch they are crucified then they're set on fire so that they serve as
还是这只是当时空气中弥漫的普遍情绪，而他顺水推舟？或者他只是反映了这种情绪，诸如此类。所以，关于尼禄指责基督徒并将他们逮捕，然后以非常非常典型的尼禄式方式将他们处死的传闻是：他们被浸透了沥青，被钉在十字架上，然后被点燃，这样他们就可以作为
torches um nero uh kind of wanders around dressed as a charioteer looking at them so it's kind of he's playing the role of the sun um he's visiting on them a kind of, you know, the punishment that is appropriate to arsonists. There's a huge amount about this passage that is unclear. It's unclear why the Christians are being accused of it. It's unclear exactly how it is that Nero has even become aware of their existence. Because they must be so tiny at this point. Are they in Rome?
火炬；尼禄……到处闲逛，穿着战车御手的服装看着他们，所以这有点像他在扮演太阳神的角色；他在对他们施加一种——你知道的，与纵火犯相称的惩罚。这段话中有大量内容是不明朗的。目前还不清楚为什么基督徒会被指责为此事的罪魁祸首。目前还不清楚尼禄究竟是如何甚至意识到他们的存在的。因为他们在这个时候一定规模非常小。他们在罗马吗？
Yeah, and also it can't be many of them. It is the only mention of Christians being blamed for this that we get in any of the sources. And well, I mean, overtly. And so there has a guy called Brent Shaw, has a scholar called Brent Shaw, has posited that perhaps it didn't even happen. I mean, I think that that really requires you to manipulate the evidence severely.
是的，而且人数也不可能很多。这是任何史料中唯一一次提到基督徒因此事被怪罪的地方。而且——我的意思是，公开地。因此，有一个名叫布伦特·肖的人，一个名叫布伦特·肖的学者，曾提出假设，认为这甚至可能根本没有发生过。我的意思是，我认为这确实需要你严重地操纵证据。
But there are kind of mysterious qualities to it. And it's because of that. I mean, I think that clearly Nero did target Christians, I guess, because they were kind of weird, sinister cultists. Nobody knew anything about them, but they were convenient. Presumably they had a kind of apocalyptic element. They were subversives. They were to hand.
但它带有一种神秘的特质。正是因为这一点。我的意思是，我认为很显然尼禄确实把基督徒作为了打击目标，我猜是因为他们是一群奇怪、阴险的邪教徒。没有人了解他们，但他们很方便。大概他们带有一种末日论的色彩。他们是颠覆分子。他们就手边。
And so he blames them. And then that gets reflected in the Book of Revelation, doesn't it? So this is Luke Wilson's question. Do you think his name fits the number of a man 666 in the Book of Revelation 1318 when written in the Hebrew form Neron Kezar. I don't know if I'm saying that right. So what's going on there, Tom? I don't understand any of this.
于是他把罪责怪在他们头上。然后这在《启示录》中得到了反映，不是吗？所以这是卢克·威尔逊的问题。你认为他的名字符合《启示录》第13章第18节中一个人的数字666吗，当用希伯来语形式“Neron Kezar”书写时。我不知道我有没有发音正确。那么那里到底发生了什么，汤姆？我对这一切一无所知。
I'm out of my depth here. So the number of the beast is 666. Yeah. And applying the prism of Hebrew numerology, that transliterates into Neron Caesar. And so... Does it really? Or is this Dan Brown talking?
我这可真是超纲了。所以野兽的数字是666。是的。通过希伯来数字学的棱镜来应用，这可以音译为“尼禄·恺撒”。所以……真的吗？还是这是丹·布朗在胡说八道？
No, absolutely it does. This has been recognised right from the beginning. Okay. So essentially Nero is the beast. And it's not just in the book of Revelation that Nero appears. So there's a late first century text called the ascension of isaiah um which has a kind of wonderful description of nero as um as beliar and it goes beliar the great ruler the king of this world will descend who has ruled it since
不，绝对是这样的。这一点从一开始就被认可了。好的。所以本质上尼禄就是那头野兽。而且尼禄出现的地方不仅仅是在《启示录》中。所以有一部公元一世纪末的文本名为《以赛亚升天记》，其中对尼禄有了一种精彩的描述，将其描述为彼列，它写道：“彼列，伟大的统治者，这个世界的国王将降临，自世界诞生以来他就一直统治着它，
it came into being yea he will descend from his firmament in the likeness of a man, a lawless king, the slayer of his mother. So that's casting Nero as a literally cosmic figure of evil. And that again, in a way, is a kind of tribute to Nero's charisma. You have to be a figure of incredible potency, I think, to convincingly be cast as the beast or the devil or the great ruler the king of this world in contrast to you know god who i mean i don't want to i don't want to prejudge anybody but i don't think kirsten is ever going to be described as the beast is he no no but i mean even you know even putin or trump i mean you know they're just not on that level they're not they're not able to correspond to
是的，他将从他的穹苍中以一个男人的模样降临，一个无法无天的国王，他母亲的谋杀者。”所以这把尼禄塑造成了一个字面意义上的宇宙级邪恶化身。而这再次在某种程度上是对尼禄个人魅力的某种致敬。我认为，你必须是一个具有难以置信的潜能的人物，才能令人信服地被塑造成野兽、魔鬼或这个世界的伟大统治者国王，与上帝形成对比——我的意思是，我不想——我不想对任何人妄加预判，但我不认为基尔斯滕（注：此处指Keir Starmer，英国政治人物）会被描述为野兽，对吧？不，不，但我的意思是，甚至——甚至普京或特朗普——我的意思是，你知道，他们根本不在那个级别上，他们做不到——他们无法与
that. Although there is a kind of interesting, again, a kind of counterpoint to this, because wherever you get people saying Nero is a monster, you also get other people who kind of love him. And a very unexpected group of people who really do like Nero, are the second, third, fourth century rabbis, who claim that Nero didn't commit suicide, that he faked his own death, that he went to Judea and he converted to Judaism, and he fathered a long line of rabbis whose writings are part of the Talmud. So that's a kind of counterpoint to the Christian perspective. I would love it if that were true, Tom. It's a great story, isn't it? And again, kind of so brilliantly unexpected.
那个相提并论。尽管这里也有一个有趣的、同样是某种对立面的观点，因为无论你在哪里听到人们说尼禄是个怪物，你也会听到另一些人有点喜爱他。而一群非常出乎意料、确实很喜欢尼禄的人，是公元二、三、四世纪的拉比们，他们声称尼禄并没有自杀，他伪造了自己的死，他去了犹太地并皈依了犹太教，他还孕育了长长一系的拉比，他们的著作成为了《塔木德》的一部分。所以这可以说是对基督教视角的一种反向呼应。如果那是真的，我会很高兴的，汤姆。这是一个很棒的故事，不是吗？而且同样地，是那种如此绝妙的出乎意料。
And the thing is that, of course, the first century AD, you've got this incredible swirl of prophetic stuff. You've got the death of Jesus. You've got the burning of the temple in the Judean revolt, which breaks out under Nero. And you've got all these prophecies that talk about how a king is going to rule the world coming out of Judea, which obviously feeds into Christianity. Jews are obsessed by it. It helps to inspire the Jewish revolt, but it does also feed into the posthumous reputation of Nero and he gets bundled into these prophecies. And there are lots and lots of people who say that like you know just as Christians say that Jesus will come again there are lots of people who say that Nero will come
关键在于，公元一世纪时，你正经历着这种令人难以置信的预言风暴。你经历了耶稣的死。你经历了在尼禄统治下爆发的犹太起义中圣殿的焚毁。你听到了所有这些预言，它们讲述着一个将要统治世界的国王将从犹太地走出，这显然融入了基督教。犹太人对此着迷不已。这有助于激发犹太起义，但它也确实融入了尼禄死后的声誉中，他被卷入了这些预言之中。有非常多的人说，就像——你知道的，正如基督徒所说耶稣将会再次降临一样，有许多人说尼禄将再次
again um and and lots say that he will come rather in the form of the devil that he will bring chaos and disaster to the world but there are also those who say that he will come and he will bring a an age of justice and peace. Let's get on to Nero's exit. So we had a good question from Jeff Costello about that. But it's for last words, which I'll ask in a second. But just before that, you know, you've presented a vision, a version of Nero that I think a lot of historians would probably go along with. That, you know, he's the showman and the performer and a populist and all these things, and that he's obviously not a madman
降临——并且许多人说他将以魔鬼的形式归来，他将给世界带来混乱和灾难，但也有人说他将归来，并带来一个正义与和平的时代。让我们来谈谈尼禄的退场。所以我们收到了杰夫·科斯特洛关于此事的精彩提问。但这关乎临终遗言，我稍后会问。但在那之前，你知道的，你提出了一个愿景，一个我想很多历史学家可能会赞同的尼禄版本。那就是，你知道的，他是一个演艺人员、表演者、民粹主义者以及所有这些东西，而且他显然不是一个疯子，
and he's not just a completely deranged sadist. And it's easy to see why the crowds, who are probably sick of senators talking about probity and Roman rigor and stuff, they're probably sick of all that and they you know, probity and Roman rigor and stuff. They're probably sick of all that. And they love a bit of gladiatorial action and watching people being set alight and free bread from Egypt or whatever. Well, actually, interesting.
他也不仅仅是一个完全精神错乱的虐待狂。而且很容易理解为什么那些可能已经厌倦了元老员们大谈正直、罗马严谨之风的民众——他们可能已经厌倦了这一切，你知道的，正直和罗马的严谨之风什么的。他们可能已经厌倦了这一切。而他们热爱一点角斗士的动作场面，看着人们被点燃，还有来自埃及的免费面包之类的。不过，事实上，这很有趣。
I mean, Tacitus does say that the sufferings of the Christians are so great that people do slightly turn against him. Okay. Well, that's interesting. But my question is, what goes wrong? Why does anyone turn against him? Why does it all, you you know why do people um what when the julio claudians have been there now for five emperors what is it that nero does that is sufficiently shocking to turn senatorial opinion
我的意思是，塔西陀确实说过，基督徒遭受的苦难是如此之大，以至于人们确实略微开始反对他了。好的。好吧，这很有趣。但我的问题是，究竟是什么出了错？为什么会有人反对他？为什么这一切——你知道的，为什么人们——当朱利奥-克劳狄王朝已经历经五位皇帝之后，尼禄究竟做了什么，才足以令人震惊到让元老院的舆论
so dramatically against the entire dynasty because he is the end of the whole dynasty isn't he i mean it's not just his reign it's the whole story comes to a crushing conclusion in that year of what is it year four emperors when he gets kicked out yeah well so there have been escalating conspiracies against him the most notorious is one that revolved around a guy called piso um and this is the one that drags down seneca so seneca gets implicated in that and essentially gets told to commit suicide, which he dutifully does. Nero then goes on this tour of Greece where he races in the Olympic Games
如此戏剧性地反对整个王朝？因为他是整个王朝的终结者，不是吗？我的意思是，这不仅仅是他的统治，整个故事在那个所谓的四帝之年迎来了粉碎性的结局，也就是他被赶下台的时候。是的，所以针对他的阴谋一直在升级。最臭名昭著的是一个围绕着一个名叫皮索的人展开的阴谋，这就是那个把塞涅卡也拖下水的阴谋，所以塞涅卡也被牵连其中，基本上被勒令自杀，而他也依言照做了。尼禄随后开启了希腊巡游，他在奥运会上参加了
with his 10 horse chariot. Most people only have two or four. And people always laugh at this because he crashes and has to be given a new chariot and he doesn't complete the race, but he still wins first prize. But the thing is, I mean,
十马战车比赛。大多数人只有两匹或四匹。人们总是拿这个取笑他，因为他撞车了，不得不换一辆新战车，而且他没有完成比赛，但他依然赢得了头等奖。但问题是，我的意思是，
it takes courage to do that. It would take courage to compete in, you know, if someone who isn't a professional Formula One driver to compete at Monaco or whatever. So while Nero's away, further rumours of conspiracy start to brew. The following year, news comes of of a open rebellion in gaul um then another open rebellion in spain led by the 70 year old martinet called galba um and nero there are all kinds of stories that he says that he's he's going to go and uh play the liar to the rebellious soldiers
做这件事需要勇气。如果一个不是职业一级方程式赛车手的人去摩纳哥或其他地方参赛，那将需要极大的勇气。所以当尼禄不在时，关于阴谋的更多谣言开始酝酿。第二年，传来了高卢爆发公开叛乱的消息，接着又传来了西班牙爆发另一场公开叛乱的消息，领导者是那个70岁的老派军事独裁者加尔巴，而关于尼禄有各种各样的传闻，说他声称自己要前去——呃，去向叛军弹奏里拉琴，
and they will burst into tears and then they'll you know that's how he's going to fight them but again this is counterpointed to he's actually clearly um quite energetic in his response he musters what troops he can he sends them north to combat the revolt in gaul um and then all kind of rumors reach him but um that basically these troops are turning against him, that the whole thing is falling to pieces. And the commander of the Praetorians, who's an absolute shit, even by Nero's standards, basically turns on Nero, I think because he sees a kind of outside chance that he might be able to grab the um uh the the empire for himself so nero suddenly finds that he doesn't have any troops in rome and he is intending to flee to alexandria where he'd
然后他们会泪流满面，然后他们就会——你知道的，这就是他要对抗他们的方式。但同样地，这与他实际上表现出的——显然相当积极的应对方式形成了对比，他召集了他能调集的一切部队，将他们向北派去平定高卢的叛乱，随后各种谣言传到他耳中，说是——基本上这些军队正在倒戈，整个局势正在土崩瓦解。而禁卫军统帅——即使按尼禄的标准来看也是个彻头彻尾的混蛋——基本上背叛了尼禄，我认为是因为他看到了一种微乎其微的可能，觉得也许自己能够趁机攫取——呃——帝国。所以尼禄突然发现他在罗马已经没有任何军队了，他原本打算逃往亚历山大港，在那里他会非常受欢迎，
be very popular um muster muster troops there um but then he changes his mind um he he flees rome he ends up in a um a villa on the outskirts of Rome. And the news is brought to him that the Senate has declared him a public enemy and that he's going to be sentenced to a horrible death when he gets found. And so he commits suicide. But what has he done to provoke these conspiracies, Tom? I mean, why does the guy in Gaul, or Spain rather, Galba, why are they not being paid?
并在那里集结军队——但随后他改变了主意——他逃离了罗马，最终落脚于罗马郊外的一座别墅里。随后消息传到他耳中，称元老院已宣布他为国家公敌，一旦被找到，他将被判处可怕的死刑。于是他自杀了。但汤姆，他究竟做了什么来激起这些阴谋？我的意思是，为什么那个在高卢的人，或者说在西班牙的人，加尔巴，为什么他们没有拿到军饷？
Is there some policy that's outweighed them or I think I think it's you know it's Nero enjoys shock and his entire reign has has been a kind of riff on offending the sensibilities of the very powerful
是不是有什么政策让他们难以承受，或者我认为——我认为你知道的，尼禄喜欢震惊，而他的整个统治一直是对大权在握者的敏感神经的一种不断试探和冒犯。
he's just pushed them too far I think he's pushed them too far it on offending the sensibilities of the very powerful. He's just pushed them too far. I think he's pushed them too far. It coincides with a period of famine in Rome, so that's bad luck for him. Yeah. And so the sense that both senatorial and popular support for him is wobbling give people, you know, people are always predatory, the chance to strike.
他只是把他们逼得太紧了，我认为他把他们逼得太紧了。对大权在握者的敏感神经的一种不断试探和冒犯。他只是把他们逼得太紧了，我认为他把他们逼得太紧了。这恰逢罗马发生饥荒的时期，所以这对他来说运气不佳。是的。因此，无论是元老院还是民众对他的支持都在动摇的这种感觉，给了人们——你知道的，人们总是伺机而动，寻找出手的机会。
Yeah. And now that brings us to Jeff's question, finally. Were his last words really, a great artist dies with me, or variation thereof? Well, that's what Suetonius says. Well, Suetonius says that his last words are qualis artefacts perio. And so that's traditionally translated as what an artist dies with me. But there's, I think, very convincingly, a scholar called Edward Champlin, who's written the best book on Nero, argues, I think, very convincingly that artefacts
是的，现在这最终把我们带到了杰夫的问题。他的临终遗言真的是“一个伟大的艺术家随我一同死去”，或者是类似的话吗？嗯，苏埃托尼乌斯是这么说的。嗯，苏埃托尼乌斯说他的临终遗言是“Qualis artifex pereo”。所以这传统上被翻译为“一个艺术家随我一同死去”。但我认为，有一位名叫爱德华·尚普林的学者，他写了关于尼禄最好的书，他的论证非常令人信服，他认为“artifex”
actually means a kind of artisan, a workman who's employed to do building work. And essentially, that's what Nero is doing in the kind of this rubble-strewn house, is that he's been reduced to this level that's what he's saying he's saying you know he was a great artist but now look at me i've just become a stage hand so it's almost the opposite of of what people traditionally think he said um and you know in a sense that that is the kind of i guess for Nero it's it's the horror is that in the end he doesn't have a death that he feels would be appropriate to him. He doesn't go out in the kind of blaze of tragic glory.
实际上指的是某种工匠，也就是受雇去做建筑工作的工人。基本上，尼禄在那种瓦砾遍地的房子里所做的事，正是将自己贬低到了这个水平，这就是他所表达的意思。他说的是，你知道的，他曾是一个伟大的艺术家，但现在看看我，我刚刚沦为了一个舞台布景工。所以这几乎与人们传统上认为他说的话完全相反。呃——而且你知道的，在某种程度上——我想对尼禄来说，最恐怖的是，到头来他并没有获得他认为与自己身份相称的死法。他没有在一片壮丽的悲剧辉煌中谢幕。
It's rather pathetic, even bathetic. And there's a horrible description in Suetonius' account that after he's committed suicide, he gets a free man to help him slit his own throat. The blood pumps out. Centurion comes galloping in, tries to staunch the flow with a towel. But it's too late. And we're told that his eyes bulged horribly. Oh, God, that's no way to go, is it? So two last questions.
相反，这显得相当可悲，甚至十分滑稽。苏埃托尼乌斯的记载中有一个可怕的描述，说在他自杀后，他找了一个被释奴来帮他割断自己的喉咙。鲜血喷涌而出。一名百夫长骑马冲进来，试图用毛巾止住血流。但为时已晚。据说他的眼睛惊恐地暴突出来。哦，天哪，这可真不是个好死法，对吧？所以最后还有两个问题。
One is about succession. So Nero's dead. Why is it such a shambles to sort out who comes next? Why is nobody agreed? Because you have Galba, Otho, Vitellius and Vespasian. Yeah. And why is that such a kind of mess? Why haven't all the opposition agreed on,
一个关于继承。所以尼禄死了。为什么弄清楚谁来接替他会变成这么大一个烂摊子？为什么没有人能达成一致？因为你有了加尔巴、奥托、维特利乌斯和韦斯帕芗。是的。为什么这会变成这么大一个烂摊子？为什么所有的反对派都没有就——
I mean, why have they got no candidates? Because people have assumed that a descendant of Augustus should rule. And when Nero dies, and effectively he's the last of the descendants of Augustus, all the others have been killed or died. All kinds of portents are seen, you know, trees planted by Livio wither and perish. There's a cypress tree in the forum, its roots spread all the way to, you know, across the forum and that dies as well.
我的意思是，为什么他们没有候选人？因为人们一直认为奥古斯都的后代应该统治。当尼禄死去、且实际上他成为了奥古斯都后代中的最后一人时，所有其他人要么被杀，要么已死。人们看到了各种各样的凶兆，你知道的，由利维娅种下的树木枯萎凋零。广场上有一棵柏树，它的根一直蔓延到——你知道的，横跨整个广场，那棵树也死了。
So all these kind of portents are seeing that something terrible has happened. And so the question is, can you have rule by a Caesar if there are no longer any Caesars? And in a way, Claudius has blazed the trail because he wasn't a Caesar, but he's been voted the name of Caesar as a kind of title by the Senate. And so effectively, this is where the idea that the name Caesar is shorthand for an emperor rather than a family name comes in. But obviously, if you don't have to have a descendant of Augustus ruling the world, then basically anyone can become Caesar. And that's the great discovery. And that's why Nero dies in 68. And the year 69 is known as the year of the four emperors, because you have four people all kind of scrambling after it.
所以人们看到了所有这些凶兆，觉得发生了可怕的事情。于是问题就变成了，如果没有了任何恺撒，你还能由一个恺撒来统治吗？在某种程度上，克劳迪斯开辟了先河，因为他不是恺撒，但他被元老院作为一种头衔投票授予了“恺撒”之名。所以，基本上，这就是“恺撒”这个名字不再是家族名、而是成为皇帝代名词这一概念的由来。但显而易见，如果你不需要奥古斯都的后代来统治世界，那么基本上任何人都可以成为恺撒。这就是伟大的发现。这就是为什么尼禄在公元68年死去，而公元69年被称为“四帝之年”，因为有四个人都在争夺这个位置。
It's very Game of Thrones. Why don't they ever, why don't they just restore the Republic? Or is that just not possible now that they're running a big empire? You know, it's kind of like, you know, why don't we go back to the political system of Queen Victoria? I mean, it's just, you know, it's just impossible. So effectively, you need an emperor at the head. And, you know, what's interesting about the year of the four emperors,
这非常像《权力的游戏》。为什么他们从来不——为什么他们不干脆恢复共和国？或者说，既然他们现在管理着一个庞大的帝国，这根本就不可能了？你知道的，这就好比，你知道的，为什么我们不回到维多利亚女王的政治体制中去？我的意思是，这简直——我的意思是，这根本不可能。所以实际上，你需要一个皇帝来掌舵。而且，你知道的，关于四帝之年有趣的地方在于，
so there are those four emperors, Galba, Otho, Vitellius, Vespasian. Two of those emperors are close associates of Nero. Otho, although he'd been exiled effectively to go and rule Portugal, he'd been kind of Nero's chief friend in the equivalent of the Bullingdon Club. Right. And had actually at one point been married to Papaya. So he's George Osborne to Nero's David Cameron. Yes, exactly.
所以有那四位皇帝：加尔巴、奥托、维特利乌斯、韦斯帕芗。其中两位皇帝是尼禄的亲密伙伴。奥托，尽管他实际上被流放去统治葡萄牙，但他曾可以说是尼禄在“布灵顿俱乐部”同等级别圈子里的首席好友。没错。而且实际上在某个时期曾与波帕埃娅结过婚。所以他就像是尼禄那个大卫·卡梅伦的乔治·奥斯本。是的，完全如此。
Exactly. And so when he comes back, he plays the Nero card. He puts up Nero statues. He pays for the Golden House to continue to be developed. Vitellius also is uh he's very fat isn't he he's very fat but he's he's he's very you know he's he he likes nero he he casts himself as the heir of nero and it's only because ultimately the guy who wins vespasian is um you know a rough hewn well kind of like you dominic he's he's a a true born son of the soil
完全如此。所以当他回来时，他打出了尼禄牌。他竖起尼禄的雕像。他出资让金宫继续开发。维特利乌斯也是——呃，他非常胖，不是吗？他非常胖，但他是——他非常，你知道的，他喜欢尼禄，他把自己塑造成尼禄的继承人，只有当最终获胜的那个人——韦斯帕芗——他是一个粗犷的、嗯，有点像你多米尼克，他是一个纯正的乡土之子——
my camera analogy he's kind of middle middle italy he's kind of eric pickles eric pickles guy yes and the joke is always that he looks like he's straining to have a shit which is very not near a perfect perfect um analogy then isn't it um so and so basically he he succeeds in establishing a dynasty so for the first time um an emperor gets succeeded not by one but by two sons, tied to the commission. And this dynasty, the Flavians, after Vespasian's family name,
用我的相机类比，他有点像中部意大利人，他有点像是埃里克·皮克尔斯，埃里克·皮克尔斯那种人，是的。而笑话总是说他看起来像是在拼命拉屎，这非常不——尼禄，完美的、完美的类比，不是吗？嗯——所以，基本上，他成功地建立了一个王朝。所以这是第一次，一个皇帝的继承者不是一个，而是两个儿子，
their legitimacy depends on blackening Nero's name. And so that ensures that basically Nero will be regarded as a monster. But there is evidence from across the empire, not just in the immediate aftermath of Nero will be regarded as a monster. But there is evidence from across the empire, not just in the immediate aftermath of Nero's death, but for centuries after that Nero is remembered
与这个委员会捆绑在一起。而这个王朝，以韦斯帕芗的家族名命名的弗拉维王朝，他们的合法性依赖于抹黑尼禄的名声。因此，这确保了尼禄基本上将被视作一个怪物。但有来自帝国各地的证据表明，不仅在尼禄死后的直接余波中，而且在之后的几个世纪里，尼禄一直被
in various communities across the empire very positively. And so is it because of Christianity then that Nero becomes, I mean, he's probably the one emperor that most people, if you stop them in the street and said, name a Roman emperor, I'm guessing, apart from Julius Caesar, obviously wasn't a Roman emperor, Nero is probably the one that would get name-checked the most. Is that because of Christianity, do you think,
帝国各地的不同群体以非常积极的方式铭记着。那么，是因为基督教，尼禄才变成——我的意思是，他可能是这样一个皇帝：如果你在街上拦住一个人，让他说出一个罗马皇帝的名字，我猜，除了尤利乌斯·恺撒（显然他不是罗马皇帝）之外，尼禄大概是那个最常被点到名字的人。你认为这是因为基督教吗，
because he's the beast and all this stuff? I think it fuses with the legacy of the two great accounts of Nero's reign that survives tacitus and satonius both of whom um they they often give kind of different accounts of what you can see is basically the same kind of incidents but they're clearly coming from the same page and so that there's a to that extent there's a kind of coherent image of nero which then fuses with with the christian portrayal of him as literally diabolical to create an image of him as the ultimate Roman emperor. And so there's a fantastic line in the Marquis de Sade's horrible novel, Juliet.
因为他是那头野兽以及诸如此类的东西？我认为这与关于尼禄统治的两个幸存下来的伟大记载的遗产融合在了一起——塔西陀和苏埃托尼乌斯，他们两个——他们经常对你可以看出基本上是同一类事件给出不同的说法，但他们显然出自同一页纸，因此在某种程度上存在着一个连贯的尼禄形象，然后它与基督教将他描绘为字面意义上的魔鬼的形象融合在一起，创造出了他作为终极罗马皇帝的形象。因此，萨德侯爵的可怕小说《朱丽叶》中有一句精彩绝伦的台词。
Juliet's this kind of terrifying murderess. And her tutor in evil is this woman called Cleo. And she says of Nero, Oh, Nero, I will always honour your memory. Were you still alive, I would worship you. You will be forever my ideal and my God. And so the Marquis de Sade is in charge of Nero as the kind of great idol.
朱丽叶是一个极其可怕的女杀手。而她邪恶的导师是一个名叫克莱奥的女人。她这样评价尼禄：“哦，尼禄，我将永远纪念你。如果你还活着，我会崇拜你。你将永远是我的偶像和我的神。”所以萨德侯爵将尼禄奉为伟大的偶像。
But as I've said throughout, I think that to have that kind of notoriety, you have to have a kind of charisma. There have been lots of kind of terrible kings and emperors who've done terrible things, but they don't have this kind of – it is a kind of glamour. I mean, his notoriety is glamorous. It's the glamour of evil, though, isn't it?
但正如我自始至终所说的那样，我认为要拥有那种声名狼藉，你必须具备某种个人魅力。曾经有很多可怕的国王和皇帝做过可怕的事情，但他们没有这种——这确实是一种魅力。我的意思是，他的声名狼藉是具有魅力的。但那是邪恶的魅力，不是吗？
I mean, isn't that basically why people – and of performance, I suppose. It's a perform of glamour i mean his notoriety is glamorous the glamour of evil though isn't it i mean isn't that basically why people and a performance i suppose it is that it's a formative evil yeah yeah yeah yeah but but i think you know i i i can't think of a major ruler whose artistic sensibility was more creative than nero's. You love Nero. I think in a way. It's unbelievable. That's why his reputation blazes in the way that it does. Yeah. 2,000 years after his death.
我的意思是，这基本上不就是为什么人们——还有表演，我想。这是一种表演性的魅力，我的意思是，他的声名狼藉是迷人的，不过是邪恶的魅力，不是吗？我的意思是，这基本上不就是为什么人们——还有表演，我想这就是一种塑造出来的邪恶，是的，是的，是的，是的——但是我认为，你知道，我——我——我想不出哪个主要统治者的艺术敏感性比尼禄更具创造力。你爱尼禄。我想从某种程度上来说。这简直难以置信。这就是为什么他的声誉会以那种方式大放异彩。是的。在他死后两千年。
Well, you think he's uxorious. So I think. I think he is. Your standards are. The most charismatic uxorious ruler. Well, there you go. The great man has spoken. Tom Holland has proclaimed his verdict and um
好吧，你觉得他对妻子百依百顺。所以我想。我想他是这样的。你的标准是。最具魅力的百依百顺统治者。好吧，就是这样。伟人已经开口了。汤姆·霍兰德已经宣判了他的裁决，而——
that's nero so tom we'll be back later in the week with with the history of france oh yeah so we mentioned we mentioned nero as as a houseman but we will actually be talking about the real houseman yeah very good uh paris with agnes parier that's right and uh the world cup and the world cup of Gods. So this, so yes, you'll be listening to this if you get it immediately
这就是尼禄。所以汤姆，我们会在本周晚些时候带着法国历史回归——哦，是的，所以我们提到了尼禄作为——作为住房建造者（注：此处有个谐音梗，将奥斯曼男爵Georges-Eugène Haussmann与Houseman谐音），但我们实际上将讨论真正的奥斯曼男爵，是的，非常好，呃，与阿格尼丝·帕里耶一起聊巴黎，没错，还有——还有诸神世界杯。所以，是的，如果你在
on Monday and the World Cup of Gods will be going on today and tomorrow and all the way up to Thursday. Tom and I don't know, we don't know who will be knocked out.
周一立即收听，你就会听到这个，而诸神世界杯将会在今天和明天以及一直持续到周四进行。我和汤姆不知道，我们不知道谁会被淘汰出局。
That's, I mean. Yeah, we don't even know what the draw is at this point. No, it's that excitement, isn't it? Before the narrative is set in stone. So dramatic. That's what sport's all about. Yeah, it is. I should say, if you've got absolutely no idea this point no it's that excitement isn't it before the narrative is set in stone so dramatic
那是，我的意思是。是的，我们现在甚至都不知道抽签结果是什么。不，那种兴奋感，不是吗？在叙事尘埃落定之前。太戏剧化了。这就是体育的全部意义所在。是的，确实如此。我应该说，如果你对
that's what sport's all about yeah it is so excited i should say if you've got absolutely no idea what we're talking about and and fair enough um if you go to our twitter twitter accounts or at the rest history uh online then you'll find out all about the world cup of gods and how you can vote and on that bombshell's goodbye from me, and it's goodbye from him. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
不，那种兴奋感，不是吗？在叙事尘埃落定之前。太戏剧化了，这就是体育的全部意义所在。是的，确实如此，太令人兴奋了。我应该说，如果你完全不知道我们在谈论什么，而且这也可以理解——如果你访问我们的推特账号或@theresthistory在线平台，那么你就会了解关于诸神世界杯的一切以及你如何参与投票。带着这个重磅消息，我向大家道别，他也向大家道别。感谢收听《历史余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取专属单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。